Musik Ich weiß schon, dass es arg in die Hose gehen wird. Ja, natürlich. Aber dieses Scheitern ist auch immer... Manchmal hat mich irritiert ein bisschen, dass das Licht von meiner Webcam an ist. Das wird mich auch... Das ist wahrscheinlich FaceTime-Auswahrsehende angemacht. Nee, ich glaube, das hat was mit Skype zu tun. Skype! Ich glaube, es hat ganz viel mit Virus zu tun, ganz viel mit Viren. Skype, Skype, Skype,, Skype, Skype, Skype, Skype, Skype, Skype, bring mir hundert Nazi Skype! Meine Damen und Herren, was jetzt folgt, ist ein live improvisiertes Hörspiel, gewollt von Twitter-User XYZ93. Ich möchte mich im Vorhinein davon nicht distanzieren, weil ich bin gespannt darauf heute mal.
Weil Sie ja vielleicht ganz im Hater.
Ja, ich habe das nicht erwartet. Ich bin gespannt darauf, was jetzt passiert. Mir ist es egal, was alle Hater sagen. Äh, Spiele sind kacke. Und deswegen präsentieren wir Ihnen jetzt die ungekürzte Version des zweiten Teils des Hörspiels. Viel Spaß. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu unserer Sendung Schicksalsschläge. Wir haben gerade verabschiedet am Telefon Mareike. Sie hat uns erzählt, wie sie lange daran gelitten hat, süchtig zu sein nach Twitter-Sternchen. Nun, wen können wir als nächstes begrüssen in unserer Sendung. Hallo, mein Name ist Tim. Hi. Hallo Tim, wie geht's dir? Ja, ganz gut eigentlich, mal wieder. Also ich hab so Phasen im Leben, da geht's mir ganz gut, da geht's mir nicht so gut, aber ich hab gerade einen guten Tag, würde ich sagen. Möchtest du uns von deinem Schicksalsschlag erzählen, was ist denn passiert? Ja, also bei mir ist es eigentlich so, ich kann mittlerweile keine Ratschläge von Menschen mehr annehmen.
Also das fällt mir ganz schwer, Ratschläge von Menschen anzunehmen.
Das ist so im Groben das, mein Schicksalsschlag.
Also ich kann mal ein Beispiel geben vielleicht, wo das alles angefangen hat,
wo ich glaube, dass alles angefangen hat.
Mir hat ein Freund geraten, Mensch Tim, du musst eigentlich
immer Ja sagen, weil wenn du immer Ja
sagst, dann erlebst du auch viel.
Und dann habe ich mir das zu Herzen genommen
und dann am Tag darauf hat der
gleiche Freund gesagt, komm,
wir bauen uns Flügel aus
Papier und springen von dem Haus da drüben.
Und
dann habe ich das gemacht, dann habe ich diesen Ratschlag
angenommen natürlich.
Ja, und seitdem habe ich kein Unterleib mehr. Es tut mir sehr leid, die Zuschauer, das ist natürlich nicht zu lachen. Ich kann mir natürlich vorstellen, dass ihr Leben dadurch eine starke Veränderung durchlaufen hat. Wie ist das denn genau passiert? Also, sie standen auf dem Dach mit den Papierflügeln und was ist dann passiert? Ich kann mich nur ganz schwer an die nachfolgenden Minuten erinnern. Entschuldigung, es wird mir sehr schwer, darüber zu sprechen. Aber im Grunde genommen war es so, wir hatten halt echt gedacht, das kann schiefgehen. Deswegen haben wir auch viele Dynavierblätter genommen. Nicht nur eins, sondern auch gleich fünf haben wir genommen. Und sind dann auch relativ schnell runtergesprungen. Und dann hat uns quasi das Trambolin nicht interessiert, weil er stand auf der anderen Seite. Und tja, dann sind wir genau auf den Betonparkplatz gefallen und ja, seitdem habe ich keinen Unterleib mehr. Aber du warst ja früher ein sehr optimistischer Typ, so ein Glas-halb-voll-Typ. Hat sich das geändert? Nee, ich muss sagen, mein großes Vorbild ist der Samuel Koch von Wetten, das?
Hey Samuel, hey, this goes out to you.
Ja, genau, da habe ich ja gelesen, Sie haben ja heute auf Twitter gepostet, das kann ich vielleicht mal hier direkt mit einbeziehen, Sie haben gepostet heute, die Hitze ist
echt zu viel heute, ab ins Freibad und dann noch ein Bikini-Emoji.
Ja, meine Freunde wissen das, verstehen diesen kleinen Gag. Man muss ja auch Spaß machen, auch drüber. Ich kann ja kein Bikini mehr tragen in dem Sinne, weil ich ja ... Haben Sie denn früher auch Bikinis getragen? Ja, so aus Spaß immer mal. Immer mal wieder habe ich das angezogen und haben auch alle gelacht darüber, das geht jetzt nicht mehr und weil man man dafür ja auch ein Unterleib braucht, das ist ja ganz klar, hat er auch Zweiteiler, und das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Aber Freibad lasse ich mich deswegen trotzdem nicht verderben. Das ist ein tolles Erlebnis. Und ich meine, ich bin immer noch ein Glas-Halbvoll-Typ, ich bin immer noch ein No-Ris-No-Fun, das ist mein Motto-Typ. Ich bin immer noch ein … Sie sind ja sozusagen halbvoll, könnte man …
Ich bin halb.
Hauptsächlich bin ich halb.
Das kann man so sagen.
Ich hoffe, ich bin Ihnen jetzt nicht zu nahe getreten, aber man muss ja auch mit Humor … Nein, man muss darüber lachen auch können. Man muss darüber lachen können. Das hält mich auch nicht ab, weiter von Dächern zu sprengen. Wollen Sie vielleicht noch gerade Ihre E-Mail-Adresse rausgeben? Meine E-Mail-Adresse ist einhalbertim at gmail.biz. Wie lange haben Sie diese E-Mail-Adresse jetzt schon? Die habe ich seit dem Unfall mir gemacht. Da hat Google dann automatisch angeboten, wollen Sie das nicht gleich in ein halber Tim, weil so ganz, also das kann ja nicht mehr sein jetzt eigentlich. Also die E-Mail- Reste, die jetzt haben, ist ja falsch, haben die mir dann geschrieben.
Und da habe ich relativ schnell gesagt, ja, das haben die auch recht. Die sind auch nicht blöd von Google. Gut, wir haben ja für jeden Gast, der so mutig ist, in unserer Sendung über seinen Schicksalsschlag zu sprechen, ein kleines Geschenk. Wow, dankeschön. Ja, was ist es denn? Da bin ich ja ganz gespannt. Und wir werden hier gesponsert von Adidas. Und da haben wir natürlich jetzt ein kleines Präsent für sie vorbereitet. Also die neuen, na ja, also die sind Sportschule. Oh, ja. Ich lese mal den Text vor.
Die neuen Adidas Air Breezy Sneaker sowohl für die Tanzfläche als auch für das Fitnessstudio geeignet.
Damit ziehen sie nicht nur an ihren Gegnern vorbei, sondern sehen dabei auch noch top aus. Jeder wird ihn hinterhersehen, wenn sie diese tollen Sneaker tragen. Für den Athleten, aber auch auf der Couch zu Hause, wenn man mal die Beine hochlegen möchte. Es tut mir wirklich sehr leid. Auch dann eignen sich die Adidas Air Breezy. Ja, bleiben Sie einfach am Telefon und … Das macht auch gar nichts. Ich ziehe Schuhe auch ganz gerne mal an. Das sieht auch gar nicht so schlecht aus. Möchten Sie noch jemanden grüssen? Ich möchte meinen ehemaligen Verein grüssen, meinen ehemaligen Verein Trambolinsport. Meine ganzen Freunde. Es tut mir wirklich leid, Tim, Sie unterbrechen zu müssen. Wir haben gerade auf Twitter ganz viele Tweets bekommen. Wir haben ja die Umfrage gemacht. Wir haben ja den Wochenjackpot und wo die Hörer immer abstimmen dürfen, wer den gewinnen darf. Und ja, tatsächlich, die Statistik ist relativ klar. Es haben sehr viele Leute für Sie gerade gestimmt in den letzten fünf Minuten.
Wow, danke.
Und ja, Sie haben tatsächlich auch den Wochenjackpot gehabt. Wow, das ist ja echt, das habe ich gar nicht erwartet, so was, dass ich so viele jetzt bekomme. Das ist ja auch nicht leicht für mich auf der anderen Seite, deswegen freue ich mich da jetzt auch schon. Vielen Dank. Er mutigt mich dann auch. An unserem Sponsor ab in den Urlaub.de.
Ich lese wieder, also zu...
Ich lese wieder, also es zu...
Ich lese einfach den Text vor.
Wer wandern liebt, für den ist dieser Dreitagesausflug in die Alpen der wahre Hochgenuss.
Nicht nur können sie...
Es tut mir wirklich sehr leid, aber vielleicht können sie ja mit... Sie werden drei Tage lang auf einer Berghütte übernachten, mit der beliebtesten Skipiste Deutschlands tatsächlich im Anschluss. Da gibt es bestimmt auch Möglichkeiten, dass Sie irgendwie auf ein Skateboard ohne Räder, dass Sie da oder irgendwie… Das habe ich auch schon mal mitgeschnallt, also mit Gaff am Tape auf ein Skateboard geschnallt, das geht alles. Ich bin überzeugt, dass auch der Ausblick bestimmt … Ja. Also Sie haben ja sonst nicht so den besten … Also wenn Sie dann vielleicht … Oder wenn Sie einfach nur die Piste runterrollen, ist bestimmt auch … Nee, das ist alles okay.. Das ist bestimmt auch sehr … Das ist doch gut, ja. Nein.
Gut, Tim, dann vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ich denke, die beiden Gewinne sind ja auch bestimmt was für dich.
Nee, die sind ja sehr …
Bleib einfach in der Leitung und …
Wenn jetzt noch zum Psychologen durchgestellt, eigentlich, finde ich ganz gut.
Wir machen … Die Sendung ist jetzt tatsächlich vorbei.
Kein Psychologen mehr. Ja, vielen Dank, Tim. Ja, gern, dankeschön. Dass Sie da waren, bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu einer neuen Folge von Das! I tell you what you want, what you really, really want. I tell you what I want, what you really, really want. I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna.
Wollen wir kurz durchzählen, ob wir da sind?
Eins, zwei, drei.
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen nochmal an.
Ja genau, okay, lass hören. Ja, da wird es dann sehr hoch für die Ukulele. Habe ich eben schon gesagt, es wird dann sehr hoch. Da ist noch irgendwann die Möglichkeiten vorbei. Ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich, meine Damen und Herren, zur heutigen Ausgabe des Podcast-Ufos. Mein Name ist Stefan Will und gegenüber von mir sitzt mein Kollege Florentin Tizek und da.
Tizek, herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu das Podcast-Ufo der neuen Edition. Mensch, wir sind wieder da. Es hat ja ein bisschen gedauert, glaube ich, oder auch nicht. Ich weiss es nicht. Es ist immer schwer, die hohen Töne zu moderieren. Es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig. Fand ich sehr schön, tatsächlich, gerade deine, also muss man ja auch mal, man muss ja nicht alles immer so unser Kasse stehen lassen. Fand ich sehr schön, gerade dein kleines Stück tatsächlich. Das habe ich mitgebracht auf dem Instrument. Ukulele, ein sehr unterschätztes, naja, eigentlich nicht, es ist furchtbar nervig, es ist auf allen Klassenfahrten verhasst. Diese Erfahrung habe ich gemacht, es wird irgendwann mit Schulranzen nach einem geworfen, relativ schnell, nach fünf Minuten, weil die Akkorde, die man darauf spielen kann, relativ begrenzt sind, irgendwann ist es vorbei. Aber sonst ist es ein sehr schönes Instrument, die Ukulele. Heute, herzlich willkommen, liebe Leute, zum Thema Freizeitparks. Freizeitparks? Was gefällt euch an Freizeitparks besonders, was gefällt uns noch weiter? Ich dachte jetzt, das ist unser Thema der heutigen Sendung. Freizweigparts, das habe ich jetzt vorbereitet. Okay. Ah, shit. Kannst du deine fünf Anekdoten, die du zu Freizweigparts vorbereitet hast? Also ich habe jetzt zu Freizweigparts, also ich war letztens im Wald unterwegs und da gibt es ja Zweige, du, boah, ey, das ist ja echt krass, wenn du nicht so oft im Wald unterwegs bist, ich bin ja nur einmal in der Woche im Wald, ey, was da für Zweige rumliegen, das ist echt schon krass, weil du denkst dir, ich kenne eigentlich, ich habe alles gesehen, aber dann gehst du nochmal und dann denkst dir, halter Vater, ey, das sind schon echt Zweigparts dabei und das ist krass. Können eigentlich, können jetzt eigentlich diese Zweige, die quasi wie ein Y-Sedon geformform sind, kann man damit, das frage ich dich jetzt als erfahrenen Waldmenschen, kann man damit Wasser finden? Ja, tatsächlich. Ja, das ist so. Weil das ist ja durch die Molekularstruktur 2H und 1O, ist ja auch diese Dreieckfunktion, die natürlich durch diesen Zweig ideal eingefangen wird? Und die logische Schlussfolgerung ist natürlich, dass das den irgendwie ausschlägt. Und als ich natürlich auch immer fragen kann, wie hat der erste Mensch der Welt, der das gemacht hat, warum hat man ihm das geglaubt? Was war das für ein Typ, der gesagt hat, Kinder, pass mal auf, ich habe hier diesen Stock, kennt jeder von euch, hat jeder schon hundertmal, hundertmillionen mal in der Hand gehabt, auch so rum wahrscheinlich, weil ihr crazy Freaks seid. Ja, ich habe jetzt damit Wasser gefunden, dass man nicht sehen kann, dass unter der Erde ist. So, das ist jetzt gerade passiert. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, was war das für ein Typ, das die Leute gesagt haben? Moment, ich kenne mich nicht damit aus, aber ich glaube, Grundwasser ist ja generell in unseren Gefilden eigentlich überall, oder? Grundwasser ist erstmal überall. Also wenn man quasi irgendwo stehen bleibt mit dieser Wünschelrute und sagt, gut, hier drunter ist Wasser, wir graben mal danach, wir graben mal noch einen zweiten Tag danach, wenn man Pech hat. Und dann hat man plötzlich, kommt man irgendwann auf Wasser und die feiern den als Gott. Kann man ja sagen. Ja, und dann Jackpot natürlich. Jackpot, die glauben dem alles. Was ich mich gefragt habe, es gibt ja immer so diesen Gedankengang, so dem zeige ich's. Ja. So irgendwie, wenn dir jemand irgendwas antut und du sagst, boah, jetzt aber, dem zeige ich's. Meine Frage, wurde es dir schon mal gezeigt? Also gab es schon mal jemanden, der es dir gezeigt hat? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage jetzt. Weil die Seite beachtet man ja oft nicht irgendwie. Also man denkt zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, die Ex-Freundin ist mit jemand anderem zusammen. Ja, und dann sagt man, okay, der zeige ich's jetzt. Und man wird dann total erfolgreich und dann hängen überall Plakate von einem in der Stadt Stadt und man denkt sich dann, die Ex-Freundin läuft an den Plakaten vorbei und denkt sich jedes Mal, ah, jetzt, scheiße Mensch, jetzt wurde es mir aber gezeigt, Mensch, das war jetzt echt verrückt. Oder dann ist ja immer der andere Gedankengang, ist das gar nicht so? Und sitzt die Ex-Freundin zu Hause rum und lebt ihr Leben und denkt überhaupt nicht mehr daran nach, ob es ihr gezeigt werden könnte, ja oder nein. Du falsifizierst also gerade, du sagst, also diese Theorie stimmt deiner Meinung nach nur, oder du überprüfst die Theorie, indem du versuchst, sie zu widerlegen. Indem du guckst, wie ist es dir schon mal egal? Was kommt auf der anderen Seite an? Wenn einer, den du befragst, jemals sagt, nee, mir hat es auch nie jemand gezeigt, ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass man es niemandem zeigen kann. Willst du das dann sagen? Genau, und dass man auch von deiner eigenen Position aus aktiv nicht versuchen sollte, es jemandem zu zeigen. Ich glaube sehr wohl, dass man es jemandem zeigen kann, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wenn jemand sagt, mir wurde es noch nie gezeigt, dann hast du vielleicht einfach nur einen saukolen Typen getroffen. Und das heißt nicht unbedingt… Ja, ich habe heute echt überlegt, ob es mir schon mal gezeigt wurde, aber wahrscheinlich schon, vielleicht verdrängt man das auch. Von Eltern wird einem wahnsinnig aufgezeigt, aber nicht mit diesem Willen, ich zeige es dir jetzt mal, sondern hey, ich zeige dir mal was. Zum Beispiel da oben, da ist eine Wolke, also immer noch ganz klein. Jetzt ist so ein Typ, es gibt ja so Segways, aber die nach dem Prinzip funktionieren, dass man sich in die Richtung lehnt, in die man fahren will, und die gibt es jetzt auch, aber nur mit einem Rad, dass man so auf einem Rad steht, so ein Koffer. Und da ist letztens jemand an mir vorbeigefahren und ich habe mich für einen kurzen Moment gefragt, hat der es mir gerade gezeigt? Weil der sah schon so aus, als würde er es mir zeigen wollen. Ich glaube, ich habe die Befürchtung, alle Segway-Fahrer sind gedemütigt worden und setzen sich dann auf Segway, stellen sich dann auf Segway, um den Leuten es zu zeigen. Das sind von der Gesellschaft ausgestossene Menschen, die sich dann profilieren wollen und das der Welt zeigen wollen, indem sie sich auf Segway stellen. Ich glaube, da wurde eine Menge gezeigt durch diese Segway. Genau wie Leute, die einen Sylt-Aufkleber auf dem Auto haben, die in dem Sinne es einfach nur der Welt zeigen wollen. Wir waren schon mal auf fucking Sylt. Was finde ich damals, also wer ist eine Leistung gewesen, da musste man nach Sylt schwimmen oder man musste mit einem Floss die Nordsee überqueren nach Sylt. Das heißt, du, Stefan Titzel, stellst die Theorie auf, dass heutzutage die Dinge so einfach sind, dass es gar nicht mehr möglich ist, irgendwas zu erreichen, womit man es jemandem wirklich zeigen könnte. Auch wenn du heute sagst, hey, ich habe es geschafft, in eine tausend Kilometer entfernte Stadt zu kommen, dann hat die Leute vor hundert Jahren gesagt, boah, oi, oi, oi, Mensch, puh, da lag jetzt aber eine Menge Zeigen in der Luft. Ja. Heutzutage eher nicht. Nee, genau. Also was ist das deine Aussage? Nee, es ist, meine Aussage ist so, man kann es Leuten relativ schnell zeigen, mit einem Segway zum Beispiel, aber es ist sehr einfach. Und deswegen muss man dann einfach mal so dran gehen, wenn man einen Segway-Fahrer sieht, darf man nicht mit der Attitüde dran gehen, oh, der hat es mir gerade gezeigt, sondern okay, das könnte ich auch. Aber dann wird es spannend, was kann man nicht? Deswegen finde ich zum Beispiel Physiker, die sich sehr lange in ein Thema hineingedacht haben und mir dann Wissen vermitteln, wo ich drüber staune, die haben es mir gezeigt. Oder Leute, die sich wahnsinnig, die die Pyramiden gebaut haben damals, die haben es mir gezeigt. So, Leute, die sehr viel, sehr viel Arbeit in was gesteckt haben und sehr viel, was man so
nicht einfach machen könnte aus dem Stehgreif. Das stimmt schon.
Oder die diese Motivation nicht aufbringen würde. Die haben es
einem gezeigt. Ich habe letztens auch mal festgestellt, also man
analysiert sich ja manchmal so selbst, so was macht
was, wo ist man schon weit, wo kann man noch Dinge
nachholen und ich habe für mich festgestellt, ich lasse
mich zu oft lumpen.
Tatsächlich. Und das will ich
irgendwie an mir ändern. Magst du mal kurz die Redewendung,
magst du mal kurz die Redewendung für unsere Leute aus der Eifel erklären? Nee, ich will mich einfach nicht so oft lumpen lassen. Du möchtest die Redewendung nicht anders in den Raum stellen. Okay, du kennst die Redewendung nicht. Ich kenne die Redewendung. Also, ich bin mir sicher, dass ich die Redewendung kenne, aber nur für unsere Hörer aus Bereichen Deutschlands, wo man das nicht sagt, sich lumpen lassen. Warum gehst du automatisch davon aus, dass es nicht jeder kennt? Das kennt, glaube ich, nicht jeder. Nein, das kennt nicht jeder. Warum musste die Feedline sofort schon in Stücke reißen, bevor sich der Gag überhaupt entwickeln konnte? Stefan, so funktioniert das nicht. So funktioniert das nicht. Wir können nicht auf dem Humorkongress antanzen und hier sagen, wir sind die grossen Humor-Checker, wenn wir uns einfach selbst
regelmäßig komplett verhauen.
Das geht nicht, so funktioniert das einfach nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wo du hin willst. Wo willst du hin?
Führ mich, nimm mich an der Hand. Nach Hause.
Nimm mich einfach nach Hause. Nimm mich an der Hand
und sag mir, wo du hin willst, mit diesem
Lumpen lassen. Du musst die Zuhörer an der Hand
nehmen, wir müssen zugänglicher werden.
Wir sollten keine Sprichworte mehr benutzen.
Wir sollten niemanden mehr an der Hand nehmen. Wir sollten vor allem keine Themenorte mehr benutzen. Wir sollten niemand mehr an der Hand nehmen.
Wir sollten vor allem keine Themen mehr machen,
die wir selber nicht in Worte fassen können,
für eine Folge benutzen,
weil es die nicht gibt zum Beispiel.
Also sollten wir eigentlich immer mit einem Thema in die Folge gehen.
Und das wäre heute zum Beispiel so eine Folge gewesen,
wo man mit dem Thema hätte reingehen können.
Ich präsentiere jetzt
Ihnen das Podcast-Ufo der Woche-Thema.
Das Thema.
Der erste Mensch.
Nein, nein!
Wir machen der erste Mensch. Der erste Mensch ist gestorben.
Aber da wollte ich nochmal mit dir drüber sprechen.
Lass sie los, lass sie fliegen.
Damit wollte ich nochmal mit dir drüber sprechen, und zwar vor der ganzen versammelten Mannschaft.
Du bist der Meinung, der erste Mensch ist tot, ich bin der Meinung, überhaupt gar nicht, weil erstmal gibt es immer noch erste Menschen, die irgendwas gerade zum ersten Mal machen, was gegebenenfalls lustig ist. Dann finde ich das massiv beleidigend gegenüber unseren Hörern, die tolle Vorschläge gesendet haben, und du der Meinung bist, dass nur weil Hörer mittlerweile schon Vorschläge gemacht, ist diese Rübrigkeit tot. Das ist eine hörerfeindliche Ansicht, bin ich der Meinung. Und dann finde ich, auch in der Vergangenheit gibt es noch lustige Dinge, die man aufarbeiten könnte. Zum Beispiel, ich gebe dir ein Beispiel, ich bin nicht anders, hau einfach nur drauf und habe kein Beispielapparat, ich habe ein Beispielapparat. Früher, der erste Mensch, der einen Luftballon verschenkt hat. Er hat einen Luftballon verschenkt, und zwar ist es einfach nur, wenn man mal überlegt, ein Plastikgebilde mit seinem Atem.
Er hat einfach nur seinen Atem verschenkt, und zwar ist es einfach nur, wenn man mal überlegt, ein Plastikgebilde mit seinem Atem.
Er hat einfach nur seinen Atem verschenkt. Das ist lustig, wenn man darüber nachdenkt.
Entscheiden Sie selbst, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, ob diese Rubrik tot ist oder nicht.
Ich finde, manchmal muss man Rubriken auch einfach loslassen, die müssen weiterziehen in die Welt und atmen.
Aber ich finde, die hat so viel Potenzial. Wir können sie erst mal in der Ecke liegen lassen und atmen lassen, aber ich weiß aus eigener Erfahrung mit Lebensmitteln, wohin das führt.
Ja.
Du hast Bock heute, ne? Du hast so richtig Bock heute.
Ja, okay, Entschuldigung, ich habe gerade nicht aufgepasst.
Das ist gut, das ist eine gute Voraussetzung, wenn man so zweit redet.
Wir fangen nochmal an, sorry, wir fangen nochmal an, nochmal von vorne.
Fangen wir von vorne an.
Okay, Entschuldigung. Wir fangen nochmal an. Sorry, wir fangen nochmal an. Nochmal von vorne. Fangen wir nochmal von vorne an. Okay.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Fuck it.
Fragmente.
Wir fangen nochmal von vorne an.
So, und hier hört die Ukulele auf, Töne zu erzeugen.
Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu Das Podcast UFO.
Herzlich willkommen, Unplugged.
Die Unplugged Version, wir haben heute keine Mikrofone, wir reden quasi direkt zu euch,
als wären wir bei euch im Raum forgett, das war ein scheiß Gag zum Reinkommen.
Wir starten einfach nochmal. Es wird auch immer besser. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu Das Podcast-Ufo anplagt, hier direkt auf der Waldmeister-Krauselbühne in Bersel. Und bei uns zu Gast natürlich wie immer Stefan Titzel. Titzel, hallo, guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren. Und das Podcast-Ufo wäre nicht, dass die Medien-Coup, wenn wir nebenan nicht noch einen Gast hätten, der wie immer reist und lockerflockig durch die Themen führt, sein Name ist Florian Tienwill. Hallo. Hallo, vielen Dank. Ja, jetzt muss ich tatsächlich weiter moderieren. Das hat der Stefan Titzel ganz gut eingewickelt. Das habe ich gestimmt eingewedelt. Eingetitzelt hat er das, Mensch. Eingetitzelt hat er das. Ja, ja, geht doch. Geht doch, ganz schön. Meine Herren, wir haben heute wieder eine Peke-Pakke-Folge-Pakke-Show für Sie. Das können Sie gar nicht glauben. Uns wird ganz warm, weil wir so viel Jacken anhaben und noch einen Rucksack aufgeschnallt. Du bist doch einer, der warmsaft, das finde ich ja gut. In der Sendung noch mal so schön die Gags reingestopft haben, haben wir uns den Jutebeutel voll gemacht. Wieso, was sagst du denn statt warm? Nee, viele Leute sagen warm. Und warm macht das Wort halt so. Nein, das war ich jetzt gar nicht so gemein. Habe ich jetzt gar nicht... Alsokt im Sprachpedantischen. Überhaupt gar nicht. Das war so unsympathisch geworden. Du bist so fucking unsympathisch geworden, seitdem du alles weißt. Jeder Mensch redet und damit kannst du automatisch jedem schon mal direkt reingrätschen. Damit kannst du es jedem zeigen. Ja, ich habe auch gelernt, wie man atmet, wie man geht. Und alles, was Menschen immer machen, kann ich jetzt, ich kann Menschen korrigieren. Das ist das, was ich will. Aber ich finde, man sollte viel häufiger warm sagen. Ich finde, die Leute leben viel zu sehr in Extrem. Ich meine das ja auch. Ich will einen anderen Punkt machen. Ich will einen anderen Weg gehen als du. Lass mich mal los jetzt. Du klammerst dich immer mit deinem Scheisssprachthema an mir fest. Lass mich mal los, ich will jetzt hier rechts abbiegen. Ich will nämlich sagen, dass ich finde, dass die Leute viel zu sehr in Extremen denken. Sie sagen immer, boah, es ist heute so krass glühend heiß, ey, so heiß war es seit 10.000 Millionen Jahren nicht mehr. Nee, einfach mal realistisch sein und sagen, heute ist es warm, es wird wahrscheinlich noch wärmer und dann tatsächlich am heißesten Tag des Jahres kann man sagen, heute ist es so mega fucking super heiß, ich bin kurz davor zu fusionieren, Bitch, das geht dann, ja, aber nicht immer dieses oh, du bist der unfreundlichste Mensch der Welt, oh, ich rufe die Polizei raus aus meinem Haus, ja immer dieses dramatische, Extrem. Ja, das stimmt, mir ist auch mal aufgefallen, also ich bin auch selber so ein extremer Typ, also ich sage immer, ich sage neuerdings zu jedem Ding, was ich gut finde, sage ich, grossartig. Wow, das Video, was du mir gesteht hast, ist grossartig. Der Film ist grossartig, wo ich mir dann auch immer denke, du machst dir gerade selber das Leben schwer. Also wenn der Film jetzt grossartig war. Ja, fantastisch. Was ist denn da noch drüber? Was ist denn noch über grossartig? Es gibt ja keine Steigerung mehr von grossartig. Was ist denn da noch drüber? Nein. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich einen besseren Film sehe, ist wahrscheinlich da. Es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es einen besseren Film sehe, aber der kann man nicht besser sein, weil man eine Wörter erschöpft hat. Was ist denn da los? Man muss sich auch mal genau denken, was Worte überhaupt bedeuten. Ja, fantastisch zum Beispiel bedeutet, es ist so gut, dass es überhaupt nicht mit der Realität zu vereinbaren ist, sondern dass es ausserhalb des Realitätstechnisch Denkbaren steht. Ja, das höre ich ständig. Oh, der Sex war fantastisch. Oh, du bist fantastisch. Oh, du bist der fantastischste Mensch der Welt. Ja, höre ich ständig. Ich denke mir, Leute, kommt mal ein bisschen runter. Es ist immer noch, ich bin immer noch ein realer Typ. Ich bin ein Mensch zum Anfassen. Ich bin ein Typ, der auch mal ganz normal unterwegs ist. Man muss nicht immer gleich nach den Sternen greifen. Einfach mal unten bleiben. Dein Minotaurus-Körper ist fantastisch. Das würde man sagen. Das könnte man zum Beispiel sagen. Zu dir auch sagen. Ja. Das ist auch schon aufgehört. Wie, du bist hierher geflogen zum ersten Date ohne Hilfsmittel, das ist ja fantastisch. Deinen eigenen Flügeln, das ist fantastisch. Ja, das ist ja himmlisch. Da geben dann die Worte alle Sinn. Aber heutzutage ist es ja oft so, dass die Leute, die sind ja auch ungeduldig, die wollen ja nicht immer, Leute, wartet doch erstmal, was wir schon gehört haben, das ist der schlechteste Film aller Zeiten, wartet doch mal ein paar Jährchen, schaut euch doch mal ein paar Filme an, da wird schon noch irgendwann der schlechteste Film aller Zeiten, aber man ist ja ungeduldig, man will ja mit 16 schon den besten und den schlechtesten Film der Welt gesehen haben. Aber auch immer dieses, ich habe die beste Mutter der Welt. Joach,. Woher willst du das wissen? Hast du eigentlich nicht. Genau, wie viele Mutter kennst du denn? Es gibt circa drei, sagen wir mal eine Milliarde Mütter auf der Welt. Naja, vielleicht ein bisschen weniger, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass deine Mutter davon die beste ist, ist unfassbar winzig. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube auch meine Mutter ist nicht die beste der Welt. Das sind einfach so extreme. Man sagt es einfach so leicht. Das kommt immer über die Lippen immer. Was ich letztens gehört habe. Kommt mal ein bisschen runter, Leute. Kommt du auch mal ein bisschen runter. Letztens habe ich jemanden gehört, der gesagt hat, ich finde mich eigentlich ganz okay. Hast du eine Ahnung, wie viele Menschen es auf der Welt gibt, die ganz okay sind und du denkst, dass du zufälligerweise eins zu sieben Milliarden einer davon bist? Letztens hat jemand zu mir gesagt, ich hatte heute, mein Tag war ganz in Ordnung. Hört ihr euch eigentlich noch reden? In welcher Welt lebt ihr denn? Was ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass genauso viele Menschen einen schlechteren und einen besseren Tag hatten wie du? Was ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit? So ein Schwachsinn. Leute! Neulich hat jemand gesagt, ich habe mir einen Tee gemacht. Hat der eigentlich einen völligen Schaden? Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was das für eine Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass im gleichen Moment kochendes Wasser und ein Teebeutel in eurer Tasse bei euch in der... Alter, da hört es mir auf. Ich kann echt mittlerweile mit Leuten nicht mehr reden, weil einfach so viele Leute so viel Schwachsinn reden. Das kommt mir einfach nicht ins Haus. Ich habe da... Nee. Hast du das auch das Problem, dass wenn du mit Leuten sprichst, du nicht mehr eigentlich nicht mehr darauf achtest, was sie genau sagen, sondern wie du ihnen das, was sie gerade gesagt haben, um die Ohren hauen kannst? Ja, wie ich ihnen am besten erklären kann, dass das, was sie gesagt haben, Schwachsinn ist. Also siehst du dich per se als was Besseres an? Ja. Heute ist das so ein Per-Se-Tag, ich werde das doch sehr oft sagen in der Folge. Also siehst du dich per se als was Besseres? Ey, mit Leuten, die nicht per se sind, mit denen rede ich gar nicht mehr. Ohne Scheiss. Mach ich nicht mehr. Ich hab mir gesagt, meine Zeit ist zu wertvoll, um mit nicht per se Leuten zu reden. Raus, raus aus meinem Leben. Einfach mal sagen, ich verdiene Besseres. Nur weil Leute Menschen sind, muss man sich nicht automatisch mit ihnen abgeben. Aber da bin ich ganz anders als du. Aber mal raus damit. Auch Leute, von denen ich weiß, dass ich sie nie wiedersehen werde, behandle ich gut. Einfach weil ich mir denke, du würdest es auch wollen so. Warum? Also ich würde es gerne können, wie du es immer sagst, wie du es natürlich auch nicht machst, wie deine Comedy-Persona, deine schreiblich ausgedachte Comedy-Persona sagt immer, du kannst die Seele noch nachvollziehen. Stück für Stück zusammengeschraubte Comedy-Persona, da wackelt nichts, da ist keine Luft, da wackelt nichts. Zu Weihnachten lässt du dir mal ein Erweiterungspack schenken. Ja, ja, ja. Nee, aber ich kann das nicht. Ich bin auch zu Menschen freundlich, auch wenn ich manchmal lieber irgendwie draufhauen würde auf diese Menschen, um dann sagen zu können, nachher eine geile Geschichte zu erzählen zu haben. Aber kann ich nicht. Ich bin dann auch so boring nett zu denen und bestelle denen auch immer dann noch guten Appetit. Ja, gleichfalls sage ich auch bei Leuten, die gar nicht essen wollen, die mir was zu essen geblieben haben. Aber man ist ja manchmal, wie man es macht, man macht es ja nicht richtig. Man ist ja manchmal in Situationen gefangen, wo einfach beide aufzumachen. Man steht immer an der falschen Kasse, wir kennen das. Man steht immer, zum Beispiel, letztens war ich auf einer Party, ja, dachte ich mir, okay, ich habe jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten. Moment, kurz, das war schon für mich jetzt, da war schon Konflikt in diesem Satz. In meinem Gehirn hat sich so ein, hat sich oben so ein kleiner, so ein kleiner Fehler, so ein kleiner roter Lampe ist angegangen. Das will ich natürlich nicht, dass ich dir in Zeneheit bin. Okay, deswegen wollen wir hier kurz mal unterbrechen. Du bist, habe ich gerade verstanden, auf eine Party gegangen, aber das hast du bestimmt nicht gesagt. Nee, ich habe gesagt, ich war auf einer Party, nicht dass ich gegangen bin. Du warst auf einer Party, weil sie sich zufällig in deinem Raum gebildet hat. Korrekt? Wo ich bin, ist immer Party. Wie bist du auf diese Party gekommen? Auch wenn ich alleine zusammen mit meinem Lieblingsmülleimer einen Döner esse. Das ist auch die Frage, das ist eine Definitionsfrage. Party Time! Das ist eine Definitionsfrage. Ab wann ist eine Party? Ab wann ist eine Party eine Party? Egal, ob man schwitzt oder friert, Party ist, was in einem Kopf passiert. Sag ich zum Beispiel immer. Aber dann stehe ich da zum Beispiel, dann stehe ich da neben meinem Mülleimer, denke mir, was für eine geile Party. Und man hat ja, das ganze Leben ist ja wie ein Videospiel, man hat ja immer so zwei Auswahlmöglichkeiten, was man machen kann. Entweder du bist der Depp, der die ganze Party lang auf sein Handy schaut, oder du bist der Depp, der die ganze Party lang wirre in der Luft herumschaut und awkward Augenkontakt mit anderen Leuten. Oder du bist der Typ, der gerne auf dein Handy schauen würde, wenn du es nicht zu Hause vergessen hättest, zum Beispiel. Das bin ich ja das Schlimmste. Wie oft hast du schon auf dein Handy geschaut, ohne dass du Akku hattest? Nee, andere Frage. Wie oft hast du auf dein Handy geschaut, ohne eigentlich auf dein Handy zu schauen, sondern nur um Blickkontakt zu vermeiden oder cool aussehen zu wollen. Ich öffne auch sehr oft dann Apps, wo ich denke, du hättest jetzt hier eine Nachricht theoretisch haben können, tue so, als ob ich lesen würde, aber in Willigkeit ist keine Nachricht gekommen. Ja, das Beste ist ja immer, wenn jemand anders eine Nachricht bekommt und ping und dann man weiß nicht, ob man jetzt auf sein Handy schauen soll, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man selber eine bekommen hat, ist extrem gering, aber es könnte sein, ein bisschen Hoffnung ist trotzdem noch in der Luft und man will ja auch nicht so unnahbar sein, also ist es auch peinlich, dann ist es cooler, jetzt lass uns mal ganz kurz cooles Report machen, der Sommer kommt, ja, deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt cool sein, jetzt müssen wir uns echt mal zusammenreißen, der Sommer ist fast da und wir sind auch nicht wirklich cool, Stefan, deswegen müssen wir es mal mehr ran machen. Hey, zieh mich damit nicht rein, diese komische Höhle. Na ja, na ja, angenommen, du redest gerade mit einem Girl, ja, einem heißen Girl, du bist gerade mitten im Sommerflirt, ja, du bist am Bargersee, Sommerflirt ist im Gange. Alle haben Bambusröcke an, wir haben einen coolen Tequila-Sunrise an. Dann kriegst du eine Nachricht auf dein Handy, ja, es macht laut Ping, weil du hast es natürlich auf voller Lautstärke eingestellt, weil du nie Nachrichten bekommst. Ist es dann cooler, die Nachricht anzuschauen oder sie zu ignorieren? Einerseits sagst du, ich bin der Busy Guy, ich muss natürlich mich drum kümmern, a.k.a. wenn du mir meine SMS schreibst, lese ich sie auch so vor, a.k.a. ich werde mich gut um dich kümmern, a.k.a. du bist mir viel wert, oder man sagt, du bist mir so viel wert, dass ich das jetzt einfach mal links lieben lasse, aka du bist mir so viel wert, aka ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich wirklich eine Nachricht bekommen habe. Ja, oder du bist mir so viel wert, dass ich dich beeindrucken will, indem ich dir zeige, dass ich auch noch andere Freunde habe, deswegen gehe ich ran. Man kann sich das auch zurechtbiegen. Ja, das stimmt. Also du bist mir so viel wert, dass ich dir Zeit, dass ich dich beeindrucken will mit meinen anderen Kontakten. Das kann man auch so sehen. Oder man macht einen geilen Spruch draus, irgendwie so wow, es hat gerade gepinkt. Das war bestimmt dein das war bestimmt dein Update, denn du bist ein Roboter, so perfekt wie du aussiehst. Hörst du es nicht, wie es knistert zwischen uns? Aber guck, nee, aber das ist genau mein Problem. Gott hat uns ein Zeichen, hat uns eine Nachricht geschickt. Das war wohl Amos Feil. Wichtig ist das, hör danach. Aber das ist genau das, weil ich kann mir genau vorstellen, wie Astrid danach zu Melanie geht, sich zusammen mit Steffi, Vanessa und Bianca bei einem Latte-Frappuccino bei Starbucks trifft. Und Karen, Karen ist eine fucking Bitch. Boah, Karen ist eine fucking Bitch. Die erzählt dann wieder Katrin, Katrin erzählt Susanne und dann ist natürlich wieder all over Twitter. Und die reden dann in Starbucks und sagen, ach, dieser Florentin, oh, Mensch, da haben wir zusammen mit geredet, war ein super toller Sommerflirt. Und dann klingelt sein Handy und dann guckt er auch noch auf sein Handy. Ich glaube, es geht gar nicht. So, und du denkst ja eigentlich, dass du damit was Gutes tun wolltest und sie eigentlich beeindrucken wolltest. Du denkst, dass Frauen reden wie in den Achtzigern, glaube ich auch gerade. Wie schwule Leute in den Achtzigern, ja. Wie schwule Leute in den Achtzigern, genau. Ja, aber das ist ein Problem, dass man eigentlich es anders meinte, als es angekommen ist, weil man kann ja alles, alles ist ja immer gleichzeitig so und auch nicht so. Glaubst du, dass du dir gerade Gedanken machst für dich selber oder für Leute, die uns gerade hören? Glaubst du wirklich ernsthaft, dass jemand schon mal über dich geredet hat, also in so einem Klickenkreis, wirklich so ernst gemeint? Das ist ja die Frage. Ja, das ist ja genau die Frage. Man denkt ja ständig, dass alle über einen reden konstant, weil worüber sollen die sonst reden? Nächstes Thema. Also, wir haben wieder Kritik bekommen von Leuten, die in der U-Bahn auf mich zutreten und sagen, hier, ihr macht euch das Podcast-UFO.
Und zwar hat mir gesagt, ein gewisser Herr… Ist nicht passiert, ist nicht passiert.
Ist nicht passiert, ein gewisser Sebastian hat mir gesagt, Zitat, reine seichte Unterhaltung ist einfach nicht mein Ding.
Als Antwort auf die Frage, ihm das Podcast- Podcast UFO gefällt, wie nicht so gut aus. Seichte Unterhaltung heißt ja für mich, dass man es nebenbei machen kann. Nebenbei zum Beispiel, neben dem Kochen, neben dem Knäckebrot essen. Aber hat sich ja bereits herausgestellt, dass man das nicht kann, neben dem Knäckeboot essen. Also würde ich sagen, wir haben es falsifiziert. Sag mal, wenn man eine Kirsche isst. In Ukulele ist man so ein Arschloch. Man kann immer, wenn man irgendwas gesagt hat, kann man es untermauern mit einem. Aber man kann sich auch gut rausspielen eigentlich. Und man kann, wenn der Gegner, Gegner, ich bezeichne dich als Gegner, wenn der Partner des Podcasts einen schlechten Witz gemacht hat, kann man auch sowas machen. Man kann immer kommentieren, wie ein Arschloch. Ja, ist gut. Du kannst dich aber auch in unguten Situationen einfach aus dem Raum spielen. Ich glaube, jeder hat Verständnis dafür, dass jemand den Raum verlässt, unangekündigt, wenn er sich dabei rausspielt. Und das war Stefan, der einfach geht. Ja, das kann man sehr gut machen. Wollen wir mal ganz kurz unsere fünf Abnehm-Tipps für den Sommer präsentieren? Denn die Bikini-Figur steht vor der Tür. Ihr habt vielleicht schon den einen oder anderen Tag am Baggersee hinter euch und euch gedacht, naja gut, so oft wurde ich jetzt nicht angeschaut. Und da haben wir natürlich ein paar Tipps für euch, wie ihr das ändern könnt, und zwar die Top 5 das Podcast-UFO-Abnehm-Tipps.
Wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wenn du das jetzt mitspielen könntest, diese Tonfolge, probier's mal.
Wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, dillillillillilling, die Podcast-UFO-Fitnessparade.
Everywhere you look, everywhere you go. Thema Nummer eins, Tipp Nummer fünf, auf Platz Nummer fünf. Thema Nummer eins, Tipp Nummer fünf. Mein liebster Abnehm-Tipp, mein fünf Liebster, Liebster, forget it, ist sich sehr viel Versprechen. Das hält gesund, das macht einen glücklich, das strengt die Lachmuskulatur an und dadurch nimmt man ab.
Dein Nummer fünf.
Auf mir, bei mir war es fünf. Kirschen. Wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel Kirschen anschaut, wie viele Kalorien die haben, dann muss man aber immer daran denken, dass bei den Kalorien der Kern noch nicht mit eingeht ist. Meine Nummer vier ist Almazet. Almazet ist ein Abnehmmittel, was es tatsächlich gibt, das war nicht so blöd, und keine ironische Brechung hier an dieser Stelle, was vielleicht die ironische Brechung dieses Platzes ist. Lass uns mal wieder! Chicken Wings. Weil, man liest sich jetzt durch, okay, 480 Kalorien pro 100 Gramm, wah, ganz schön viel. Was viele Leute aber vergessen, bei den 100 Gramm ist der Knochen noch nicht mit eingerechnet. Idioten! Alle lassen es liegen, deswegen ist es ja so billig, aber da ist der ganze Knochen noch nicht rausgerechnet. Kann man durchaus sagen, hey, ich hole mir ein Kilo Chicken Wings, weil man isst ja nicht alles, man isst ja nicht den Knochen und spart nur da Kalorien. Mein Platz Nummer drei, ein ganzes Glas Erdnussbutter auf einmal, weil es ist nämlich so, man denkt immer, boah, schmeckt das geil, ich traue mich aber nicht, weil es so fett ist und weil es so dick macht. Und wenn man aber so ein ganzes Glas isst, also wenn man auch allein sich einen Toaster mit schon macht, fühlt man sich dermassen eklig, dass man eine Woche lang nichts mehr essen möchte. Habe ich hochgerechnet, wenn man das ganze Jahr nichts mehr essen möchte, muss man einfach ein Glas Erdnussmutter essen. Dann kommt man das ganze Jahr ohne Essen aus. Das ist Nummer zwei oder drei. Das ist Nummer drei. Chicken Nuggets. Man liest sich das so durch. Okay, wow, 668 Kalorien pro 100 Gramm Chicken Nuggets. Ich habe mir den vier Kilobeutel gekauft. Na, wie das morgen früh auf der Waage aussieht. Aber, hier kommt der Tipp, damit ist ja noch nicht mit eingerechnet die Energie, die man verbraucht, wenn man Chicken-Mas kaut. Mein Platz Nummer zwei.
Wenn man sie kaut, da denken die Leute immer nicht dran. Das ist ja auch Energie, das ist ja Bewegung, das kostet ja Kalorien.
Das haben die aber noch nicht abgezogen, die Idioten. Das steht ja auf der Packung ohne die Kalorien pro 100 Milliliter. Mensch, da ist eine ganze Menge Kalorien, ich will eigentlich Kalorien sparen, aber... Leute, denkt doch mal nach, seid doch nicht immer so doof. Doch wenn ihr ganz viel Cola trinkt, dann müsst ihr auch aufs Klo gehen. Und dann geht ihr ja von eurem Computer ins Badezimmer und verbrennt Kalorien. Hallo, die sind so dumm, die schreiben das noch nicht mal auf die Flasche. Mein Platz Nummer zwei, sich selber erschießen. Dann hat man auch keine Probleme mehr mit dem Gewicht. Das war's von mir. Du hast noch Nummer eins und dann sind wir auch schon raus mit der Rubrik. Platz Nummer eins, treibt Sport. Ganz im Ernst, Leute, Treppsport, das ist wichtig.
Ernsthaft, also bei vielen von euch ist es auch wirklich schon umso. Es ist auch der Spaß vorbei. Es geht nicht nur um die Ästhetik, es geht auch ein bisschen um die gesundheitliche. Und wirklich, wenn ich mal die paar von euch sehe, ihr seid wirklich fett geworden, ihr seid wirklich so fett geworden, Leute in letzter Zeit, schaut euch mal an, ey, guckt euch echt... Das stimmt, dieser Beitrag wurde gesponsert vom Gesundheitsministerium NRW. Glaubst du nicht, dass Abnehmen auch so eine Sache ist, wo man in hundert Jahren zurückguckt und sich einfach denkt, Alter, die armen Schweine, ey, irgendwie einfach mal so ein Step-Aerobic-Kurs-Video sich anzuschauen, wo in der Zukunft man ja offensichtlich einfach nur eine Tablette nimmt, die einfach dafür sorgt, dass man Fett verbrennt, dass man irgendwie dann, was weiß ich, irgendwie kein Fett mehr abbaut und das ganze Fett halt ausgeschieden wird. Ich habe ja diese große Hoffnung. Weil man einfach das einfach zack umgeht. Das ist ja einfach nur ein physikalischer, chemischer Prozess, den man natürlich irgendwann manipulieren kann. Ich habe ja die ganz, ganz große Hoffnung, dass irgendwann diese Mittel, die man auf Shoppingkanälen immer sieht, zum Beispiel dieses Band, wo man sich drauflegt und dann wackelt das ganz doll und man sagt, durch diese Wackelenergie verbrennt man Fett, dass diese lustigen Methoden, die ja offensichtlich nicht funktionieren, sich später mal irgendwann als wissenschaftlich bombastisch rausstellen, die wirklich und dass irgendwann mal so die große futuristische Möglichkeit ist, Fett zu verbrennen und alle sich immer auf diese Wackeldinger setzen würden. Allein, dass man so einen optischen Gag hat schon im Alltag. Und dass sich plötzlich in jedem Tagesablauf von jedem Menschen plötzlich so eine Stunde lang auf diesem Wackelding eingliedert. Das wäre doch super geil. Das ist meine große Hoffnung für die Zukunft. Ich meine, das ist doch wirklich als Inside-Joke einfach gestartet, wo sich immer gedacht hat, okay, die Leute denken wahrscheinlich, wenn ich unglaublich bescheuert aussehe, das ist so ein Placebo-Effekt, wo ja auch Dinge, die sehr wehtun oder sehr viel Aufwand sind, einen grossen Effekt haben, ist wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche bei Abnehmmethoden. Je beschissener man dabei aussieht, desto mehr denken die Leute, es hätte tatsächlich einen Effekt. Und was sieht dummer aus, als wenn man einfach ein fetter Typ einfach geschüttelt wird. Einfach in welcher Situation sieht man als fetter Mensch möglichst dumm aus, wenn man geschüttelt wird.
Und genau das machen wir jetzt, ihr Fettis, ja? Wir fucking schütteln euch.
Maximale Demütigung. Und dann finde ich auch großartig, wenn in der Sendung danach, es gibt ja immer so verschiedene Sendungen, die ein Produkt verkaufen, und in der Sendung danach wird dann einfach so ein Ganzkörpersuit verkauft, so eine Ganzkörper-Leggings, die einen zusammenpfercht, die einfach das ganze Fett in die Traummasse zusammendrückt, die einfach sagen, die erste Sendung, gut, wir versuchen noch, lustig mit diesem Problem umzugehen und es vielleicht zu verhindern, sagen wir, und die Sendung danach hat schon komplett mit diesem Prozess abgeschlossen, das jemals loszuwerden, und einfach nur noch, ja gut, wir versuchen es noch irgendwie zu kaschieren, wir haben keine Chance, loszuwerden, wir versuchen es mal. Aber ich stelle mir mal wirklich vor, du du trägst so ein Teil und jemand bemerkt, dass du so ein Teil trägst. Sag mal, Udo, Mensch, du siehst ja echt richtig gut aus. Ja, ja, ja, ich habe ein bisschen abgenommen jetzt in der Zeit. Echt, okay, cool, so schnell abgenommen, wow, interessant. Irgendwie, Mensch, ganz schön warm, ich ziehe ja meine Jacke aus. Trägst du ein Korsett eigentlich? Nee, nee, natürlich nicht. Vor allem das ist total unpartikabel. Zum Beispiel, man ist in der Wüste gefangen. So, was macht man dann? Du kannst nicht gut aussehen und überleben mit diesem Ding zum Beispiel. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein Riesenproblem tatsächlich. Das ist voll das Problem. Da wird auch irgendwann das Gesundheitsministerium noch aufmerksam werden. Ja, vor allem, ich meine, warum willst du gut aussehen? Du willst gut beim anderen Geschlecht ankommen. Warum? Weil du Sex haben willst. Um Sex zu haben, musst du dich ausziehen. Das heisst, Dinge, die dich gut aussehen lassen, eigentlich ist es ideal. Das denke ich mir nicht immer bei, zum Beispiel bei Männern, die wahnsinnig gut aussehen und irgendwie ein Sixpack haben und muskulös sind, wo ich mir denke, in dem Moment, in dem die Frau dein Sixpack sieht, hast du ja eigentlich schon gewonnen. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ja völlig unnötig. Ja, das stimmt. Weil wenn sie dir mal das T-Shirt auszieht, dann bist du ja eigentlich schon am Ziel. Also was ist das für eine Sache? Deswegen tut einem Frauen ja auch so leid, weil sie ja am Ende kommt es ja nur auf den Penis an. Aber das ist das Letzte, was Sie sehen.
Da ist es schon völlig zu spät.
Wenn Sie das sehen, ist es schon viel zu spät. Dann sind Sie ja schon in einer Position, wo ein Zurückrudern sehr peinlich ist. Deswegen mein Tipp an alle Hausfrauen, warum auch immer an Hausfrauen, mein Tipp ist einfach das Licht ausmachen. Aber ist man dann nicht als, also ich meine, du bist ja ein netter Typ, ne? Ist man dann nicht als moralisch gefestigter Mann in der Verpflichtung, dieser Enttäuschung vorauszugreifen? Habe ich seit Jahren, versuche ich deshalb mit offenem Penis durch die Fußgängerzone zu laufen, um den Frauen zu zeigen, ihr wisst jetzt sofort, auf was ihr euch einlasst. Aber die Justiz hat was dagegen. Ja, die Justiz ist gegen Ehrlichkeit, das ist mir schon häufiger aufgefallen. Ja, aber einfach, wenn man so flirtet und es läuft gut, dann einfach zu sagen, so hey, hands off, bevor du weitermachst, wahrscheinlich wird dich mein Penis enttäuschen. Ich will es nur jetzt gesagt haben, dass am Ende nicht wieder das Geheule groß ist, dass sich da wieder die Tränen kullern, dass die Nachbarn schon wieder ankommen, Mensch, gestern hat schon wieder eine Frau bei Ihnen geweint, was ist denn da bei Ihnen eigentlich los in der Wohnung, in der Erdgeschosswohnung, da bei Ihnen zu Hause? Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich ein 1 zu 1 Louis CK-Gag, tatsächlich, glaube ich ehrlich, dass er Angst, dass er Mitleid hat, also jetzt am Ende. Wir haben das letzte Mal gesagt, wir sagen das nicht, wir wollen das nicht. Klar, es ist 1 zu 1, ich habe 1 zu 1 das Senderprogramm, wortwörtlich habe ich mir mitgeschrieben, ins deutsche Übersetzung, gerade wiedergegeben, ins deutschen. Und wir haben gesagt, wir wollen das nicht mehr angeben, wenn wir irgendwas klauen, weil es ja eh alles nicht mehr irgendwie neu ist, neuerdings. Ja, obwohl es eigentlich bei Frauen auch nicht anders ist eigentlich, oder? Aber man ist halt als Mann einfach nicht wählerisch, was das angeht, oder? Hat schon jemals jemand gesagt, nee, ist mir zu klein oder zu gross? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, wir bewegen uns auch auf Gefilde gerade, wo wir vielleicht uns nicht so zu Hause sind. Nicht so gut ausgehen, ja. Lass uns mal was Peinliches machen, damit wir uns wieder zu Hause fühlen, einfach mal. Ich bin ja wieder schlechter für irgendeine Idee. Ich finde, wir sind gerade, was Peinlichkeit angeht, eigentlich ganz gut zu Hause. Falls ihr da Erfahrungen gemacht habt, liebe Männer und Damen zu Hause, einfach mal in die Kommentare schreiben. Lasst es uns hören. Komm, wir machen mal kurz einen Vorausblick. Und zwar nächste Woche bin ich im Urlaub, das heißt, da gibt es keine Sendung. Oh. Und, du weißt noch gar nicht davon. Sturmfrei. Und danach die Woche haben wir eine ganz spezielle Überraschung für euch, die wir noch nicht verraten wollen, oder? Ah, okay, jetzt weiss ich, wovon du redest. Ach, nee, nee, nee, nee, lass die Leute mal ruhig ein bisschen zappeln. Lass die Lurich immer ruhig ein bisschen leichen. Wir haben wirklich
was Tolles für euch bereit. Wir sagen jetzt allerdings noch nicht,
was es ist, weil
ansonsten
denkt ihr, habt ihr zu hohe
Erwartungen und dann zack,
ist die Hose offen und
dann heißt es wieder,
ach Gottchen. Ich sag nur so viel,
ich sag nur so viel,
Thomas Gottschalk.
Das ist eher so ein, ja, das ist eher so ein 480p-Ding. Schlechte Auflösung. Jetzt wollte ich mal fragen, wieso hat Bruce Willis, als der kleine Junge zu ihm gesagt hat, ich kann tote Menschen sehen, so geschockt reagiert? Also ohne den Film zu kennen, würde man das ja auch nicht so verstehen, wie er es verstanden hat.
Weil man kann tote Menschen halt sehen.
Ist ja nicht so, dass sie verschwinden.
Ist ja nicht so, dass sie einfach weg sind, vom Erdboden verschluckt werden und man sie nicht mehr sieht.
Man sieht tote Menschen.
Wenn also jemand zu dir sagt, ich kann tote Menschen sehen, wäre die richtige Reaktion, ja, das kann jeder.
Das wäre die richtige Reaktion.
Oder dass du zum Beispiel bei einer Beerdigung sagst, ich sehe tote Menschen, und man dann sagt so, wow, no shit. Ja, genau. Das wäre quasi, wir hätten das quasi weitergedacht jetzt. Also es gibt wahrscheinlich noch mehrere Films. Ein bisschen gefreestyled, ja. Vielleicht ist das eine neue Rubrik, Dinge, die man nur aus Filmen kennt und die deshalb lustig sind, weil sie eigentlich hätten anders verstanden. Ist eine sehr komplisierte Rubrik mit einem sehr langen Namen. Das ist ja heute eine Express-Spezial-Folge, das heißt, sie ist genau so lang wie eine richtige Folge. Nee, nee, nee. Also, das war mal wieder eine, das Podcast-Ufo-Express-Folge. Das Podcast-Ufo Podcast UFO Pocket, möchte man sagen. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet 14 Minuten lang guten Spaß. Vielleicht haben wir die Woche noch eine zweite Folge raus. Müssen wir machen, weil ich diese Woche im Urlaub bin. Wie gesagt, da bin ich im Selbst... Wo fährst du denn hin Urlaub eigentlich? Selbstfindungstrip durch die Tropen Ruandas. Ich komme mit einer grossen Packung Gags nach Hause und vielen Krankheiten, gegen die ich nicht geimpft bin. Das ist so der Plan. In diesem Sinne, das war es von uns, das Podcast Sufo hebt ab und kommt lustig wieder, ich kann dabei nicht reden.
Du musst abmoderieren.
Das war es mal wieder von Das Podcast-Dufo.
Folgt uns auf Twitter, auf Facebook und es läuft immer noch das Gagtakulum, nur um das mal auch mal am Laufen zu halten.
Bis dahin, es kam noch nicht so viele Einsendungen, da geht noch mehr, Leute.
Mach's gut.
Tschau, wie immer. Tschüss. La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la